hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast and I'm just checking in on your
summer
[__]
um I don't even know if I'm supposed to
do one today
I think I interviewed somebody and that
covers today but whatever I got like a
half hour
you know maybe I'll just do one and I'll
just have it and I'll just save this
like maybe this will come out in the
fall and then you guys can all be like
oh it's not the summer you [__] bald
red [__] yeah it's [__] it's Autumn
is it it all feels like summer to me
that's my new novel on global warming
oh it's gonna be funny when global
warming just keeps going and then people
sing those
what's that Sinatra song
It Was a Very Good Year it was something
and something
wasn't there some song about the Autumn
of my years
everybody's gonna be like oh my God
what's that
there's only one season it's [__]
um it's hot and a little less hot
especially what happened
um
I'm in a great [__] mood even though
I got into a nice back and forth with
the lovely Nia the love of my life
you know
it's an honor to be with her
[Laughter]
it was one of those fights you know you
have with like
you know okay you're married you have
kids and the your partner just makes a
decision
about the kids and you're like wait what
the [__]
and then like well let it be a big deal
you know and then and then what I don't
know you know it was funny was I started
to get mad but then I'm like no I don't
want to yell so then I shut down
then she goes let's discuss it I go I'm
not discussing it right now I need to
process it first and then that made her
pissed
and she just went off on me
she goes and then she came back around
she's like you sit there sometime you're
gonna sit there and process it like he's
some [__] Buddha
uh I hate how funny that was the middle
of a fight and I was like yeah that's
[__] hilarious
um
whatever but I was still right you know
what I mean but you know how it is you
know how it is
just because you're right still means
you're wrong that's how it works when
you're the husband
uh but other than that home light's
great man
it's [__] great
I was hanging with somebody the other
night and they said to me hey did you
see that Wimbledon final which was a big
part of my childhood
staying inside avoiding the Sun so my
[__] skin wouldn't get like a third
degree burn
and I used to love breakfast at
Wimbledon with Dick enberg and I guess
this year was incredible and that has to
be posted somewhere
you know
is there the original version or is is
it five hours of that song oh no oh no
no no no like every [__] Instagram
video
I guess it kind of became a genre of
Instagram and then everybody was like oh
good if I hear this song like a lab rat
I know something bad is about to happen
and then somewhere along the line the
rat gets sick of hearing that [__]
song is that what it is or the rats
viewing the rat
ah bill
this is what happens when you when
you're doing a podcast and you don't
even think you need to do one the you
know what it is right now people it's
not that I'm not funny right now it's
just that the effort isn't there
you know kind of the way your wife
watches dishes you know she's an adult
she could do it the right way if she
wanted to
she sort of just the deck you know and
then you [__] grab the bowl and you
gotta
I mean it looks clean to the naked eye
to someone that actually needs trifocals
but hasn't gotten around to getting them
the plate looks clean but then you go to
grab it and you feel the film of
whatever the [__] was eating on it
the night before
and you just you know you curse under
your breath
and then there's that voice in your head
that goes you know what bill it's not
worth it it's not worth it
and then you're downstairs by yourself
you know wearing your robe
your freckled milk white calves
poking out the bottom
some old slippers you got for free from
somebody used to advertise on your
podcast
somewhere along the line you made them
mad
and you wash that dish
as you wash the dish you look up
and you catch your reflection in the
window and you see the sadness
of what your life has become when you
quietly cry to yourself
make a couple of soft crooked eggs try
to lay off the bread and then she comes
downstairs she sees your eyes are a
little puffy and she says are you all
right you said oh yeah you know I just
did get some sleep last night
and you push it down you don't
communicate it and then it just sits in
there it doesn't leave it sits in there
you know and just waits for the next
holiday
whatever it is you know Christmas trying
to put the lights on the tree
[__] is the turkey done is it not
done something like that and then that
that's when that moment
that's when that moment's going to come
out
and she's gonna be like where is this
coming from and you're not even going to
know because there's going to be so many
other of those moments buried
right there in that chest
but it's my belief if you cry enough at
the sink you can get some of them out
oh Jesus
um oh Billy big day yesterday I uh
finally did that solo flight up to Santa
Barbara
um I don't know if I made the Radio
Calls correctly to approach and then
they they had me uh
when I when I departed they put me on
with departure and I was just on with
them and after a while I was just kind
of like uh could I just go to the
comment Channel
and they were like what
I'm like yes
kind of like don't feel like I need you
guys anymore I don't know what the radio
call is
uh terminating uh departure or I don't
know what the [__] you're supposed to
say but I said it and I just sat there
like with you know one eye closed like
here it comes
uh but the guy was cool he figured it
out
um so now here's the deal
I know how to go up to Santa Barbara I
know how to uh I know the approaches the
approach to The Landing Pad
I did it with my instructor and then
this week I did it by myself AKA soloing
and the first thing I did was you know
Google places to get coffee and [__]
you know
fun places to take my wife who doesn't
value my opinion
laughs
now here's the deal whenever I I make
fun of my wife to this level you know
that she's gonna she's gonna have to
come on and give you the rebuttal
[Music]
um
you know
whatever what do you want from me
I'm just a man that flew a helicopter to
Santa Barbara and back
without hurting himself you know I did I
did an episode of the Howie Mandel
podcast
and uh he brought up that stuff and I I
don't like talking to people who aren't
Pilots because all they do is talk about
dying
and I was actually out there I'm gonna
text him and tell him this I actually
had to block out his voice as I was
doing pre-flight
um
and then I went up and I had a great
time and it was exactly what I wanted I
got out of uh the LA Basin so there was
like nobody up there
and when I got out to the coast there
was this Marine Leia
all the way out over the water and it
got about a hundred feet into the over
the land and just disappeared
because as you know from your your your
your ground studies
um water has a way more consistent
temperature it takes a lot longer for it
to heat up and to cool down where land
is like it's like a home you don't know
what it's gonna do
um oh my God she would kill me if I said
that
she'd be like I'm the water you're the
land you bald psycho and she'd probably
be right whatever land heats up and
cools off
uh very quickly so it was already like
noon time so the ground was the
temperature was much higher so what
happens don't you see is the clouds come
over and those air molecules get heated
up by the air Rising off of the land the
water molecules expand
and at that point you know when you uh
when the water molecules become
saturated that is the dew point which is
the point at which moisture becomes
visible AKA a cloud
all right I'm going to shut up here it
basically Heats it up that's what they
mean by burning it off
um so I was able to go up the coast and
I had clouds that were I was above
uh to the left of me I had the ground
below me and then on the right I had
mountains
and I was just flying right up that
Corridor it was [__]
gorgeous
and then when you get to Carpenteria
that's when you call approach you're 20
miles out
and uh for whatever reason Santa Barbara
likes you to be on with approach so
that's what I did I got on with them and
they basically at that point they're
also watching for other traffic and then
they hand you off to the Tower
and uh it's a little tricky coming in
there the first time you go up the 101
don't you see
and then once you see there's this
little I don't know this little hanger
thing when you see it the helipads are
on the other side and the altitude I'm
flying at you can't see them so I'm
always like looking for them
I'm like I know they're not that far and
once I get a little you know just a
little bit to the left of that
I'm like oh my god there they are
I'm gonna do it after all these years of
being intimidated so that was a big deal
for me
that was a big deal for me God damn it
it happened and guess what I have right
now
I have free time I'm off until the end
of July
um
knocked out those four weekends in a row
as hard as that was with the kids
um now I have all this time off with
them and all I'm doing is we've just
basically been swimming
and uh both my son and my daughter
my daughter can swim now but like she's
just just improving the skill and my son
by watching her just keeps getting
better and better and better and he is
absolutely
absolutely Fearless
which is fun from some things and then
other things
it you know scares you
and uh he's repeating everything so I
have to stop cursing because he said the
f word the other day he said God damn
and my daughter had one of her friends
over and we have this little trampoline
that has like a handle on it that you
hold on to
and her friend like sat on it and then
did like a backwards spin around
like super fast like she knew how to do
it but I didn't know that
so as her head was whipping around I was
like oh I literally went I was holding
my son and went Jesus Christ
and my son looks at me and he just goes
okay
um so there's that
so I got that going for me so I'm I've
uh I've been practicing in the car
not cursing and I it just blows my mind
how I just the effort just when I really
pay attention to it
it's the third word every time
or the second
it's either what the or the
[__] is this guy doing
what the [__] is going on here it's just
it's just
or I go oh you stupid [__]
there you go you [__] that's what it
is
always
always goes like that so I I always say
the f word now but then I stop and I go
silly person
I go what the [__] in you
you're a silly person that's what you
are you're just you're silly you're
wacky
you know
you changed lanes but you didn't get
your whole car in there you're you know
so it's still blocking the lane and
you're causing a traffic jam and people
are beeping at you and you don't
understand why
to the points you're giving them the
finger is if you're the victim
you're just a silly person
that's going to be my new code for [__]
which is just so much more static
content you know
I feel like he just gets it out of there
it's like nice [__] blunt force
silly
but maybe I can use silly is like a Sav
for my emotions as Frank sinarelli would
say s-a-l-v-e sap
um
anyway
I'm gonna try to go online and I'm gonna
try to find some of these goddamn
um
what am I even talking about I'm going
to try to find the uh the The Wimbledon
Wimbledon
is it wimble not Wimbledon breakfast at
Wimbledon I said my whole life growing
up it was breakfast at
Wimbledon
all right I'm gonna look something up
here we're gonna look up the last few
albums that Mr Burr has downloaded
all right
because I'm enjoying this music I
obviously
obviously got the uh new Queen of the
Stone Age album
had to do that
did not disappoint as always as always
you know I love about their albums I
always feel like in the beginning
I like a couple of songs and I don't
quite get the rest of it and then the
next time I listen to it
I get it even more and then by like the
third listening I'm like this [__]
album is incredible
so that's how dumb I am
so now I have it
on in my car on like a loop
and uh you know I always do AC DC on the
elliptical but in the car right now
that's that's where I am right now
um
and then I also I downloaded uh this
Cannonball Adderley album
it's called something else
Cannonball Adderley Miles Davis Hank
Jones Sam Jones and art Blakey
it was 1958 and I'm enjoying that I
downloaded another song called meet the
woo
no yeah meet the woo
uh this rapper pop smoke who I guess
unfortunately the home invasion got
killed so
rest in peace but I really like whatever
uh his the sound of his voice and the
tracks that he wraps over
are amazing so
look at that huh
if you've noticed now most people would
say that that is a very eclectic mix of
music
but I know myself well that means like
oh bill was on the road and his brain is
all over the place
just like he is he's here he's there
he's checking in he's checking out he's
on a plane he's getting off a plane I'm
gonna listen to some jazz I'm listening
to the Queen's son I'm gonna listen to
hip-hop oh [__] lunatic and then I
come home
and new rules are in place and I'm like
what the [__]
and then I get to some stupid tiff with
my wife who I don't want to fight with
because I love her
and now here I sit alone in my room you
know I'm not crying at the sink okay we
had that moment this morning
that might be the name of my next
stand-up special
Bill Burr crying at the sink
I used to do a bit about that
of course it was misogynist well it
wasn't was actually talking about how
men used to have
prevent women from
reaching their dreams and had something
to do with them there's always a window
to look out while you're washing the
dishes
that was for back in the day when women
weren't allowed to leave the house
that's what it was
so they would just look out the window
and just you know dream oh someday maybe
I can walk past that last tree that I
can see because they washed the dish
something like that something ignorant
um
had a great time the other night I went
down to The Comedy Store
and uh
I did some time down there I haven't
done that in a uh
in quite some time
just oh it feels like it anyway I really
uh
I really missed that place you know
there's something about it too and
something too like
or maybe an off night when it's not like
a uh
Friday or Saturday and people don't have
expectations it's sort of a more relaxed
Vibe down there and I always feel like
kind of feel like the history of it and
stuff
um
but anyway I went down there and I did
Adam Ray's show he does this show where
he goes in full makeup and he's dressed
as Dr Phil
and he just comes out like um you okay
on today's show um we actually have a
comedian and he's going to come out here
and Entertain You Folks and afterwards
we're going to talk we're going to talk
to him so I go out and do my [__]
and uh I act like an extra idiot you
know so when he comes out he can
psychoanalyze
analyze me you know so he came out um
okay Bill um there was a lot of anger in
that
um
so I think they're going to be posting
some clips of that but uh anyway
if you're wondering what my next flight
is going to be
um I believe my next flight getting out
of the LA Basin because I've just flown
it so much and then it's also you know
there's you're always constantly I feel
approaching another airport and I got to
talk to them instead of being able to
cruise around a little bit what was
funny when I was coming back from Santa
Barbara you go through uh I follow the
118 you know past Ronald Reagan Santa
Susanna pass and right as I come over
there
I got the atis on for Burbank
and I'm switching over to uh to Van Nuys
to see if I you know if it's cooled up
across Midfield or whatever right so
the second I get on with them they go
you know helicopter blah blah blah
turned to heading zero four zero there's
a police chase there's four helicopters
headed towards you
and I was like all right I'm back in the
LA basin
here we go
it was [__] cool so I mean they were
like you know two miles away it wasn't
like they were bearing down on me just
for people who don't fly before you get
all freaked out
so I turned to that heading and I flew
it and uh he got back on like within a
minute said you know they're now headed
south which usually happens in a car
chase it's not like the person is
driving the same way they Serpentine and
that's a big mistake OJ made or at least
his driver did they got on the 405 and
they stayed on it what you want to do is
zigzag through the neighborhood you know
make it entertaining for the pilots
you're still not going to get away but
it's it's entertaining for for the
viewers we'll say
so
um
anyway and then I ended up
getting back on course and I looked off
because I have with my avionics I can
see where the other helicopters and
planes are they have the transponder on
which of course they did and I just saw
this cluster of four helicopters
it was kind of cool like one lays back
one's out front and this looked like
there was kind of two on either side
um
and I was kind of looking at it like
that almost looks like a hockey team
when they're when the other team's on
the power play
you know and if you uh you know it's
five on four and you got the box because
I was thinking like if he did a u-turn
and went the other way the guy in the
back is now the lead do they stay in
like that formation if there's any
helicopter pilot police helicopter
Pilots out there and you want to write
in I would love to know what that's like
um anyways Sani Inez
that's the field that I'm gonna go to
next
um
and then I'm gonna do
Santa Maria after that
and eventually I'm going to work my way
up to Paso Robles
um
and kind of basically understand how to
do all of this wine country stuff
what the [__] is possible I'm sorry I'm
looking on the map here
oh there it is is that it there it is
that's not so bad
um
I just gotta find the right way to go up
there I just don't like being like
flying over mountains the whole [__]
time because God forbid you had to set
it down or whatever then what do I gotta
walk out and like you know deal with
[__] mountain lions and bears and
[__] like that I don't need that I don't
need that my [__] life I'd like to
follow a road up you know land near a
7-Eleven
great only toad what happened to you
buddy are you the feds I ain't growing
weed no no no just
I had a little problem had to set her
down
that's what I get nervous about when I'm
on the other side of the San Gabriel
mountains when I fly out there what's
great about flying out there is you have
a place to put it if you had a problem
but then the problem is is whose yard do
you land in what are they on
and you know you land in a helicopter
someone's on meth that they think it's
the cops and then what happens right
that's why I try to stay near the
highways the highways are always like
the uh
seems like the uh the DMZ right
it's probably not a good expression to
use the Dead Man's own
uh
um anywho
that's it
I'm going to play a little drums I'm
going to make up with my wife when she
gets home
um there's only one way to do that
there's only one way to make up with
your wife okay you have to give up on
calling her on what she did wrong
you just have to apologize
for whatever it is you did and then
hopefully you're married to an adult and
at that point she'll apologize
for what she did
she still doesn't mean it you know
it doesn't mean [__] to her but you know
just
that the fact that you can even get her
to give you a fake apology
I like to think is is a uh
is a minor Victory you know what I mean
it's sort of that Don BB
play in the Super Bowl where yes you
lost by 50 but he didn't quit on that
play and yes he did slap the ball away
so they didn't lose by 57.
um all right I guess at this point what
I would do
is I would read some sort of advertising
if that is in fact what I had
um had to do oh Billy boy's been [__]
reading
I read two books and a script and the
last couple of weeks and I'm very proud
of myself
you know a lot of people say I'm stupid
a lot of people are right
um I actually I have so many books that
I started and then my ADD kicks in I got
this book that Jim Carrey wrote that is
[__] amazing
Jim Carrey and Dana Vashon Memoirs and
misinformation
I'm halfway through it I stuck an
envelope in here DMV
expedite processing well I'm sure that's
not important that's my bookmark I did
that the other week with like a gig
check I couldn't find my gig check and I
realized that I tend to use important
documents as book markers
God damn it
you know they say your nose and your
ears don't stop growing your entire life
and I agree with that because I never
used to have a problem with getting
water in my ears and all of a sudden it
does so I think my ear canal has gotten
bigger on the right side
it's been driving me [__] nuts
but you know what I always think I
always think
whenever I have a problem I think you
know what as bad as this is because now
my ears ringing with the tinnitus and it
also feels like it's underwater
what I always do
when something like that bothers me like
that I just think like well you know
what as bad as that is
some guy in the middle of nowhere took
out an AR-15
and shot at a tractor that he put
dynamite in and he he was too close to
it
and he blew his Lego a blew my leg off
remember that classic video blew my leg
off I blew my leg off
one of the most fascinating things I've
ever heard he didn't scream in pain he
wasn't going oh my God what did I do
he just went I blew my leg off I blew my
leg off I think when you really [__] up
you're actually calm I saw a guy trying
to take a hook out of this little
shark's mouth and it bit down and it bit
his pinky finger off and went into the
water
with the pinky
and the guy just goes ah I bit my
goddamn pinky off
it bit my goddamn Pinky
and it took my finger Charlie
it took my pinky you think they would do
that but they don't
another one the [__] the trick
shooter I was just talking to a buddy of
mine at dinner the other night those
guys that do the [__] trick shooting
and they spin the gun around that old
cowboy
I get shot myself in the goddamn lick
son of a I I don't believe it I just
shot myself
in the goddamn leg do you think that guy
way back in the day remember that chick
cut his dick off
he was [__] around on us so she cut
his dick off
and then threw in the garbage just I
can't remember what the [__] happened
right
and uh
I wonder if he did that
she just cut my goddamn dick off
son of a [__]
all right
so well I don't know what I don't know
what I don't know what to tell you my
[__] ears ringing it's it's it feels
like it's it's [__] underwater
and uh I got a frog in my throat but you
know what I still went I still went to
the gym
and like a good soccer mom I got on that
goddamn elliptical I put on an AC DC
album that's what I do I don't do time I
do an album
I went on today was Dirty Deeds
all right
honorable mention underrated AC DC song
Love at First feel
telling you and they should use that
song rocker in a Pixar movie
if there's ever some little cute things
that they make minions or whatever and
they want to start a band or something
like that they should do their version
of it they should do a cover of that
song
in the minion voice
AC DC would make some money the kids
would laugh and they would get another
generation of fans
you know buddy of mine sent me a clip of
um
that live in Paris show that they did
right before Bond Scott died
and that is our I I would put that
concert up against any [__] rock
concert
that is ever ever been done
the sound the energy the sheer [__]
power
of that band
um
and just one of the tightest bands that
ever that ever [__] did it's amazing
if you get a chance check it out anyway
that is the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday Morning podcast
um
have a great weekend you silly [__] see
that I almost you know I was gonna say
you silly people but then I realized the
English say
silly [__] well you're in charge of
security you silly [__] did you see
Peter Grant's daughter is selling her
shares of Led Zeppelin 10 that's got to
be a hundred million dollars to own 10
percent
of Led Zeppelin has to be like that has
to be a billion dollar purchase to get
if you were to get all of it
um
I was sitting there like thinking like
how many people
would I have to get to pull together
to see if we could buy that 10 percent
you know
just you know I don't know what does
that mean do you get anything from it do
you get like a
you're the Biggest Fan patch or some
[__] some rich cunt's gonna buy it I'm
going to say that that's going to go for
175 million dollars that's what I'm
saying all right there you heard it
first
um I do not look good in a tank top no
matter how much I work out I am just so
[__] Pasty
you know I wear a tank top I look like I
should be shuffling down the hall like
holding onto an IV
I [__] hate myself all right love you
guys have a great weekend bye
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
the Monday Morning podcast for Monday
July 27
2015. how's it going how are you
oh yes over
where's the [__] summer going kid
dude you know I wanna get I want to get
some of that [__] uh who's that
politician on the beer there Sam Adams
Summer Ale kid right I drink the Selma
Ale in the summer right in the fall I
drink the one with the [__] cherries
in it and then the rest of the time I
just drink their regular laga
what's up everybody so
Oh Billy red cakes oh red velvet here
he's been trying to lose weight
let's go freckles you [__] douche go
get a tan no one wants to see your
[__] pasty legs at the beach
um
so
last week I was supposed to be 180
pounds but I was not in the facility of
a of a of a scale and by the way
somebody gave me [__] like dude what
kind of [__] respectable Hotel
doesn't have a scale
doesn't have a scale where you like that
that comes standards where you where you
stay where you staying at huh you
staying at the old Illuminati Inn huh
there's some broad come in wearing some
[__] weird mask
all [__] naked one of those [__]
perfectly shaped broads like you see in
the movie by the guy who did the Eyes
Wide Shut
it's one of the Stanley Kubrick Stanley
Kubrick has some of the hottest broads
ever in the history of film in his
movies
ever ever
you know it's just a shame horrible [__]
happens to him but you know in the midst
of the [__] you're like God damn that's
a beautiful woman
and I think that really speaks to the
beauty of a woman that something
horrible could be happening when you're
like wow
she looks like a [__] statue
with a muff all right
they never have the muffs in statues if
you notice that it's a little difficult
with the concrete what are you gonna do
huh have somebody with long fingernails
kind of come up while this concrete's
still wet and just kind of do one of
those right in the old crotch area how
does that go bill that goes yeah that's
how you do it that's how you make it you
know I took a sculpture class just like
old Adolf Hitler did didn't he or you
take a painting class
I don't know what he did it just always
makes me kind of smile thinking there
was a point in his life where he was
just thinking he was going to be an
artist you know sitting there with an
easel
you know what I mean painting some ducks
you know by a pond
and who knows maybe uh somebody Jewish
walked by and sneezed and scared the
Ducks and it just he just [__]
snapped and just sent him just sent him
down a whole other Road
you know does anybody explore that
theory
um that was offensive to ducks and
Jewish people oh this blog is gonna be
easy
um
so anyways
I'm sitting here in my office
um [__] hot as hell I gotta close the
windows on the counter I swear a lot you
know what I mean and I wouldn't want to
offend the people next door God knows I
could reach out and touch their [__]
house Reach Out Reach Out And Touch my
house
so [__] stupid this is such a [__]
stupid City I live in a city yet I live
in a house in a city
you know see and I have a yard but I but
I don't
you know what I mean gotta have the
drapes closed people just walking by
looking at you and [__]
um so anyways I'm back here so anyways I
was supposed to get down to 180 [__]
pounds I couldn't weigh myself last week
I was at the just for last Festival the
booze was flowing
all right and I stayed awake
what's that [__] crunch though ah
stay away
was it Alice in Chains
off a jar of flies I believe wow that
takes me back in the day hey let's let's
go down this add [__] stream before I
get to my official weigh-in
um I used to listen to that [__]
that [__] cassette tape when I would
be driving in my 83 Ford Ranger with the
re rebuilt Ford Cylinder that the broad
I worked with told me that was a dumb
move she was all excited that I was
going to buy a new car and my brother
told me don't do that then you change
your day job you don't want to [__]
do that so I didn't I rebuilt it I
didn't rebuild it had somebody else but
a brand new one that's what happened the
other one [__] burned up so I [__]
had a brand new one put in
cost me 1500 bucks at the time this is
the early 90s I still remember that
woman when I went to work she's like
where's the new car I said oh you know
what I decided to put a new engine in my
truck instead she just like made this
what the [__] look and just wrinkled her
nose and went that was stupid
um
[Laughter]
was it stupid
maybe I don't want to stay anywhere in
this Smock for the rest of my life all
right with you [__] uh whatever you
got there
what was it the Nissan Power Ranger what
did they make in the early 80s that
everybody loved the Maxima you get it
you're taking it to the max to your mom
Maxima Maxima
my I can't afford the payments can you
take over
I got fired for smoking weed on the door
all right I did a little blow okay I
stayed out all [__] oh you know what I
will move out
um that's what you hear in Boston
when the windows ain't closed so anyways
uh
what was I saying so I used to [__]
drive that thing
and um
oh man those are the [__] days and I
would do [__] dick Doherty's room up
and drink it I do the high five
this restaurant on top of the only
skyscraper in [__] Manchester New
Hampshire or the other [__]
the other town there what's the other
Town there's two towns in [__] New
Hampshire the rest of it is [__]
beautiful Woods streams and uh probably
a lot of people doing heroin heroines
back in a big way hey tell you this kid
has been on stage in a while let's bring
them up
um
it's the other one Nashua see them I
think it was in Manchester I used to do
the high five I used to do Bob Marley
[__] room on Old Orchard Beach and I
used to [__] listen to that cassette
tape over and over and over again the
whole way down in fact I remember coming
back down down 128. heading back down to
my house I had to work the next [__]
day
driving like 80 miles an hour and all of
a sudden I got a [__] flat tire and
um
pulling over on the side of the [__]
road one of the scariest things you can
do on the highway pulled over and uh all
they had was that you know that little
[__]
you know that awful poor excuse for a
[__] tire iron you know it's just
like the little uh when you could fit it
right up your sleeve a little L-shaped
[__] thing and I knew I didn't have
enough leverage because I'd been there
before so I always had a section of pipe
behind my seat and uh dude I changed
that thing like I don't think a pit crew
well actually a pit crew could do it but
for one person I changed that [__]
tire so goddamn fast sitting on the side
of the road I had my spare in the back
of the truck you know that section of
pipe [__] four lugs
I used to have that down
I had so many [__] Flats over the
years and that thing was such a piece of
[__] that truck that I I knew the whole
[__] routine
you know take out your spare tire stick
it under the car
you know a little bit in case it comes
slamming [__] down it hits the tire
and not your foot
right loosen all the [__] lugs with
your section of pipe on your little
[__] L-shaped thing before you raise
the [__] truck
then you jack it up all right you take
the [__] off you stick you know I used
to put the lugs right in a row there was
no cell phones I didn't have a
flashlight I had [__] nothing I'd
line them right up in the back of the
truck I used to pray to God that it
happened on the right side like that was
a good night and you stick the [__]
back on you start all four of them you
set the thing back down and you bash
what bash we're bashing in your back in
the [__] truck feeling like a man
anyways so
what was I talking I was talking about
how I uh how much weight I lost so
um so I was supposed to be at 180 last
week did not have a scale because
evidently I stay in shitty hotels
and uh this week I was supposed to be
177.
all right and I [__] worked out the
whole time I was up in Montreal I ran
the stairs Royal Park whatever the [__]
they call it
um ran those almost every day or as long
as I could I took one day off
and uh but that Dad played hockey and
absolutely [__] embarrassed myself oh
my I hadn't played hockey in like four
months and I already sucked and I went
out there and just for laughs
knew this guy who used to play for the
[__] Canadians and he looks like a
[__] movie star
come on haps fans you know who he is
huh
first number four second number four
later traded to the Devils he's got this
[__] sick ass like little mini rink
so anyways we Stefan rishay so we
[__] show up and I'm going oh my God
this [__] Stephanie
um he used to kill us and um so we
played in like the other team was just a
bunch of ringers and they came out there
and like my first shift I think I was on
the ice for like [__] three seconds
and they scored you know and I'm coming
back and immediately everybody knows
they already knew I sucked but now like
they now it's like they have like they
know how much I suck right and uh they
they the other team scored like [__]
three goals within
um
I don't know maybe a minute
and uh then all of a sudden we got like
two and then blah blah blah then they
were up like eight to five and then done
and then people you know this is
basically what happened they realized
that they were way better and they were
nice enough to let us win by one that's
what happened
I think we won like 13 to 12.
um it was a good time I had zero shots
on net never fell down though I never
went that way
did never knock me down but I was I was
uh I was awful ah man I should have
skated at least once before I went up
there and um but whatever I burned some
calories uh but thank you to everybody
there at the rink that let us play out
there I had a great despite the fact
that I was [__] horrific I had a
great time and um I don't know hockey
plays are just [__] funny guys to
hang out with anyway so everybody was
busting balls and that type of [__]
and you know guys coming in the face off
oh I'm going up against all freckles you
know giving me [__]
and then they go right around me and you
know what there was nothing I could do
about it so thanks to everybody hooking
it up and thank you to the other team
for letting us win by one or two
whatever you did it's very nice of you
very hospitable
so anyways
so now I come back
and uh I stepped on the scale this
morning it's Sunday
I was supposed to be 180 last week and
177 this week and I got on the scale
and my weight was
180 pounds even
so
so I'm three pounds behind what the [__]
I wanted to do however
I Was 80 186.6 when I started this
[__] thing so
what does a quitter do
huh what does a quitter do besides take
off her Horseshoes and walk Barefoot
back to the [__] hotel room across
the casino floor with dirty ass [__]
feet what else does a quitter do a
quitter goes like well I was supposed to
be 177 and I'm 180. forget it [__] that
last week was a wash for me all right
I'll consider that a bye week because I
was on the road so next week I got to
get down to 177. who gives a [__] as
long as I reach my goal of getting down
to 162 pounds the last time I had abs
all right this is my last big push I'm
turning 50 in three [__] years
my last hope nobody has abs in their 50s
unless you did heroin in your 20s and
that's a fact and you can [__] look
it up look at Keith Richards look at the
[__] shape that guy said despite his
horrific
habits tremendous shape you know all
those [__] guys
anybody who did the [__] smack the
key is it's not to OD and die
you get clean and I don't know what it
is man the rest of your [__] life
it's like you just have an orange and
like you you're full for [__] 10
hours I have no idea how they do it
um
I don't sound out people that did heroin
let's just say if you do hard drugs in
general
you know look at what's his face there
from that band you know that had the
puppets on the cover
you know what I'm talking about ah yeah
[Music]
all right he's [__] skinny as [__]
he's pushing 60.
um I'm not advocating doing heroin I'm
just talking about having ABS in your
50s I'm doing it oh natural so no heroin
um so anyways I feel though
I do feel by tomorrow Monday what you
listen to now not to [__] you up I will
be 179 so I'm only like two pounds
behind
um so what I'm I keep doing is I keep
switching up the [__] workout and uh
Bert [__] christcha was nice enough
to send me something about grip strength
from one of those men's magazines that
uh
I can never commit to having a
subscription to because it's just the
same thing over like all those Men's
Health magazines you know what they're
just like Cosmo if you really look at
the covers it's the same [__] every
every [__] episode or whatever you
call it every issue Cosmo's always some
[__] hot
[__] airbrush broad right there's
something else you know so and so's most
in-depth uh [__] interview ever
she's finally found happiness right or
whatever and then there's always you
know either how to get you man how do
you know if your man's [__] around
how to really please you man how to get
your man to please you we're not one of
those [__] articles and then on the
men's one
right they always got some guy who's
kind of famous right who shredded
airbrushed and all of that [__] and it's
always hard to get abs and [__] 20
days
um the Cirque du Soleil diet or some
[__] some [__] diet and then um
oh some new new [__] arm workout
that's gonna explode your biceps or some
[__] it's all the same [__] crap you
know what you got to do all right you
[__] you eat well at the beginning of
the day you have your fruits before
[__] 12 and then after that you go
veggie you have your [__] meat that
the size the Palm Behavior if even
remotely near that and you're working
out if you're doing half hour of [__]
cardio and you lay off the booze the ice
cream the chips the cookies and all that
[__] where is it gonna get a Fat's got
nowhere to hide
you turn the lights on the roaches all
[__] start scurrying
that's the first time I ever used scurry
and and [__] eight eight years of
doing a podcast
you know what you got to do you don't
need those [__] magazines but every
once in a while you get bored with your
workout you want something new so Bert
Kreischer sent me this thing I'm gonna
go back on my my Twitter history and try
and find it but he sent me this killer
[__] um
grip shrink workout
and uh one the first thing is you just
try to hang from a chin up bar in the
pull-up position
for [__] a minute three sets of one
minute and um
the key to that is just hang there
what I was doing was I was kind of in
like a like a [__] the first third of
a pull-up so I was burning up but if you
just hang that it's not that [__]
hard so now I've moved to the next one
which is you you do it again for a
minute but you hang in there holding the
bar with one hand and the other one you
drape some sort of cloth you know
whatever if you're in your garage like
me the [__] rag you used to [__]
check your oil which is probably stupid
because there's oil on it whatever that
helps with the grip strength and that
one you hold you just drape it over just
some sort of face cloth you drape that
over and you hang onto that with one
hand the other hand's on the bar you try
to do it for a minute and then you
switch hands and uh
I've been able to do it for a minute
on one side and then the other side I
did it for about 45 seconds that's where
I'm at on that thing and then of course
you're like well let me put two up there
and see if I can just hang by two
[__] rags and I almost broke both my
kneecaps that's hard as [__] for me
anyways
you know so that's where the [__] I'm at
so I'm gonna get down to 177 next week
by hook up by crook and um
I'm hanging in there with the Boost 21
days no booze I'm getting to the point
of hey you know gives a [__]
I was kidding no I can't wait for
September 15th September no September
16th is when I can boost
that's when I can uh I can booze again
but uh I gotta tell you um
the hardest place
for me to not booze actually is my house
you know why because I got the good [__]
you know you go out to a [__] bar
what am I gonna do out there I'm married
so I don't give a [__] about the women
out there you know and then I gotta
spend 10 times what I'm gonna pay at
home
and and I'm gonna drink [__] cheap
booze
right why the [__] would I do that
in fact all you youngsters out there
I know because you you know you're
single you want to get laid or whatever
but if you really want to go out for a
[__] night of drinking you want
something good it's just like eating at
home it's way cheaper
pull your [__] money together
all he is
how many it takes don't get yourself
just a [__] bottle of uh Johnny
Walker Blue just get that you know what
I mean don't put any ice on it you [__]
sip it like a [__] gentleman
telling you I don't know that you know
who you can't appreciate that in your
20s if you appreciate that in your 20s
uh you're you're you're a [__] raging
alcoholic if your palate is that
sophisticated
either out of your dad's a banker or
some [__] you know instead of you
finishing his morning coffee with some
sort of booze so you can numb the
[__] lies he was going to tell all
day oh Jesus bill could you get more
dramatic I'm sorry whatever what do you
want from me
how many times I got to tell you guys I
got an hour to [__] fill here I would
have [__] Phil over there
um all right let's get to some of the
reads for this week hey everybody you're
gonna get to listen to me read out loud
um by the way
um
no no uh no hard feelings with uh
uh DraftKings by the way you know they
explain their position to me they they
know that they're gambling they don't
give a [__] right but they're just in
business with baseball they're trying to
make their money why would I be a douche
and try to hurt them for making money
right so they said eventually they'll
come back to the podcast and I'll play
ball all right I'll play ball
what do you want from me you know
I immediately but it's probably because
I never talked to the advertisers that
helps you know
whenever they called to complain is he
available no
when is he available never
I already know what you're gonna say oh
we didn't like what you said it was like
I won the first three quarters and I
[__] it up in the end
Christ you lost the game
um
anyway so let's uh let's move on with
the podcast here a lot of [__] happened
in the news the latest person to get in
trouble
and to be branded or racist
Hulkamania Hulk Hogan it's running wild
um
The holster
having a conversation dropping the
n-word dropping the [__] inward so
then his bro his his uh his daughter
comes to his defense says he's not a
racist
you know I don't know who the [__] what
are you gonna do I mean you're dropping
the n-word that that's a rough one I'll
tell you that's a rough one you know
then he's got friends who are
African-American yet he's [__]
dropping the n-word you know what I
think it really is I think there's a
bunch of different levels
to being racist you know what I mean
it's like me I play drums but it's just
a [__] Hobby
but John Bonham was a [__] drummer
you know what I mean so like the John
Bonhams of of of racism are like in the
clan
they're in like those white supremacist
groups you know
they were in the [__] with the Nazis
you know what I mean they are
professional [__] racist this is what
they do this is how they earn a living
you know can you earn a living in the
clan
yes is it kind of like a volunteer fire
department but you but you're just
[__]
you're racist and you start fires
it's like a drum circle except you just
say hateful [__]
what exactly is the clan why would you
join the clan and then you got other
people who are more like you know
it's like they're not a professional
racist but if they wanted to be
they wanted to be they could be the
Grand Dragon in the clan they just don't
apply themselves so instead they work at
like Home Depot or some [__] right they
think just as much [__] up [__] and
then he got the person who occasionally
you know like me goes around plays drums
every once in a while these guys do the
same thing except they drop the n-word
every once in a while I think Hogan's
like right around there
you know what I mean
it's like when his daughter's saying
he's not a racist
she means like he's not in the clan he
doesn't have a swastika tattoo you know
what I mean
but he's still playing drums there you
know what I'm saying why am I relating
drums to [__] being a race I don't
[__] know
who knows he was also I looked up his
age he's 61 years old
he was born August 11 1953.
so that means if his parents had him
at like what like 25
they were born in 1928 so Jesus Christ I
mean what the [__] was his parents
filling his head up with right
his parents lived through the depression
they was already preaching that there
wasn't enough
and that black people now that they were
free we're going to take everything from
the white man that paranoia was probably
already there then they went into the
[__] depression
so maybe his parents were extra [__]
racist
so he had to crawl out of that hole and
him crawling out of that hole was having
black friends but but you know he's like
he has black friends but he's like I
don't want my daughter
to date one
so he's like you know
I'd say he's like an intermediate racist
I don't know what to tell you I don't
know what to tell you brother
um
what are you gonna do who's getting who
you know you [__] you put a tape
recorder on it and people still don't
know who knows what the [__] we would
all have to apologize for something if
somebody left a [__] tape recorder
run all goddamn day long and you didn't
know it was on Nixon lost the White
House doing that [__] you wouldn't be in
trouble
Jesus Christ the [__] [__] that I say
over the course of a day of [__]
broads and all this time that's
something something would come out
you know if they read all the texts that
you do joking around with your friends
but you know it's a [__] joke you
know what I mean
I'm not saying you dropped the N word
but come on somebody would get you
somebody get you for something
homophobic
right something I don't [__] know but
uh
what I think it's going to be a good
thing I think the guy hopefully will
learn something from it
and he won't do [__] like that anymore
hopefully he'll know that it's wrong but
I really think in moments like that you
gotta let somebody be a [__] human
being you got to take into consideration
when they were born what was fed into
their [__] heads and give him an
opportunity to redeem themselves because
if he just [__] cancel all his
[__] matches and all that [__] what
is that going to do except drive him
more towards anger
that's what I say because the other
shit's not working firing people you
know what I mean that [__] Chef there
that had the slave themed [__]
wedding do you think she's not thinking
you know I'm sure she's a little bit
better but
did that really help
I don't [__] know what am I talking
about who knows so uh
let's get back to the podcast so I oh
here oh this is what I wanted to talk
about here we go here we go so
Tom Brady
slaying all the ladies
um
he's you know he appealed the four game
suspension
and uh somebody who was speaking for all
the owners said that they were they were
all hoping that they would all the other
arms I should say were hoping that uh
the NFL would uphold this suspension
because what he did was so [__]
horrific or allegedly did you know they
can't [__] prove it or whatever
that's the thing they can't [__]
prove he did anything yet there's a four
game [__] suspension that these [__]
want to be upheld that they want to have
upheld and the number one and two people
[__] that are on their side believe
it or not are the Indianapolis Colts and
the [__] Baltimore Ravens and this is
such a [__] layup for a joke the
Ravens [__] quote let me find it here
was that the Patriots have been getting
away with murder for years
why if you're connected with the
Baltimore Ravens would you ever use the
Expression getting away with murder
these [__] teams you know they're all
sitting in glass houses and I love that
they [__] trash the Patriots for
whatever the [__] it is they think that
we're doing
you know like they're these holier than
thou people you want to talk about
getting away with murder hey how about
this at least when one of our players is
involved in a murder the [__] goes to
jail
you know at least we got that on you
the [__] Ravens
Jesus Christ in your last [__] decade
you had a guy [__]
[__] drop his fiancee
in an elevator and drag her out and you
guys were fine with the four game
suspension because all you give a [__]
about is the performance and then you
add your other guy there right
obstruction of justice in a double
[__] homicide
not only do you look the other [__]
way you let them play in the Super Bowl
he invites his two buddies there who are
up on the [__] double homicide
Chargers are sitting there in the game
and you didn't give a [__] and you're
gonna talk about Aaron
shame on you
shame on you Baltimore Ravens and I
don't have to get involved
with the Indianapolis Colts every game
that Andrew Luck starts is cheating for
the Indianapolis Colts considering how
they got him and they tanked an entire
[__] season and if you don't think
that they did that then you still
believe in Santa Claus all right I'm not
even saying my team is [__] it
innocent not by any stretch of the
[__] means I don't give a [__] if you
say my team cheats but it's when you get
on your high horse and you say that your
team doesn't cheat too that's when I say
hey you know what
I think I'm gonna walk away from this
and I'm gonna go have myself a water
with a lemon because I'm on the wagon
yeah
one of the [__] Ravens
in the Cults just own up to the fact
that you're just jealous of how long the
Patriots have been good and how many
[__] Super Bowls we've been to and
how many games we [__] won all right
you [__]
you got yourself two Super Bowls the
Ravens what's your [__] problem
Indianapolis I know what that guy's
[__] problem is it's his goddamn
personal life
um oh geez oh wow that was a low blow I
did not want to say that I didn't want
to say that but I'm just sick of this
guy trying to [__] you know of course
these [__] don't want Brady to come
back they want the Patriots to be Owen
four so they got a [__] chance at
winning a better [__] chance right
now do you think they're really outraged
at the Patriots they're not this is just
part of them the same way like you
[__] tank a season to get Andrew Luck
the same way you look the other way an
obstruction of justice or [__] you
know somebody beating the [__] out of
somebody in an elevator because you want
those players on the [__] field you
don't want Brady on the field so of
course you're going to play the outrage
card of course you're going to do that
when someone else almost beat their
[__] girlfriend to death and almost
got [__] four games not talking about
the guy from Baltimore this latest
[__] guy
all right it's complete [__]
horseshit so anybody out there who's
actually buying into this [__] yeah
you're just a patriot hater or you
believe in Santa Claus all right and I'm
never gonna hear your argument because I
don't go to sports bars
I think people who actually really think
that this is a big deal the whole
[__] deflategate thing are the kind
of people
that even in July
are sitting there wearing a a pro level
NFL jersey with somebody else's name on
the back and you got wing sauce
and yes in your [__] beard stubble
all right and you ought to be ashamed of
yourself I think it's high time you
[__] grow up what do you think about
that I don't give a [__] if Brady comes
back in game six we're still gonna make
the playoffs and we're still going to
come back and [__] hunt you [__]
right and we're going to break your
hearts in your own [__] Stadium I
don't care how loud you are all right
well if you go there dress like a bird
you know oh you got a sword in your
tooth or you're [__] eating a dog
bone they don't give a [__] they're
professionals they're gonna come in
there
and metaphorically speaking they're
gonna gut you all right so get ready for
the heartache another football season's
coming
oh I'm talking a bunch of [__] I don't
give a [__] we just won our fourth I'm a
happy fan
um speaking of which being up in
Montreal
um always makes me think of the Expos
and uh I would tell you that time I went
to an exposed game by myself
I was uh doing a gig
I might have done it was either a
college or I did the Lake Ontario
Playhouse
um way back in the day
um that's like one of the first
headlining lining gigs I got outside of
the New England area
and uh Mike Kinney I believe was the guy
who booked me up there
had a great I always loved doing that
gig but anyways um so I was up there
up on Lake Ontario and it was at that
point I was trying to go to all the
ballparks so I saw that the Expos
Ed had a game the next day so I said
[__] it so I got in my rental car by
myself and I'm crossing the Canadian
border in a very obscure place I'm not
coming up 95.
and I'm by myself so the [__]
security guard up there you know
security guard you're going to another
country country find the security guard
because walking up he's like uh he's
like oh where you going there eh and I
was sorry and I was like I'm going to a
uh an exposed game
he's like oh yeah you're going up there
by yourself
and I was like yep and he goes oh okay
why don't you pull over there eh so I
pull over my rental car and I'm like
what the [__] I never gotten pulled over
before and I'm standing there
and him and this other guy proceed to
rip my [__] rental car apart I'm like
what are they doing and then it finally
dawned on me
how put that they thought
that nobody
was pathetic enough
to drive an extra two and a half hours
to go see an afternoon Expos game by
themselves nobody was that sad of a
human being
and it just struck me as funny and I
started [__] laughing and they were
looking over at me and I had this big
smile on my face and I was laughing
because I knew they thought this guy's
got to be dealing drugs there's no way
he's actually going to an exposed game
by himself
and um
it pissed them off and they searched
even harder and then when they just
realized I was just laughing at them I
think they took extra time almost trying
to make me lose the game losing I missed
the game so I ended up getting the car
and I drove up there and I sat out in
the Outfield at Olympic stadium and I
remember they had one arm rest on the
chairs out there
and for whatever [__] reason Bare
Bones it's an Olympic [__] Stadium
it's the one that I believe Bruce Jenner
who's now Katie Caitlyn right he [__]
won the uh the goddamn decathlon there
and uh I sat out there and I watched
somebody steal home plate and I jumped
up in the [__] air freaking out that
I saw somebody steal home plate
um and nobody in the stadium was
reacting so I sat back down thinking I
didn't see what I just saw and then I
went home
and I watched TSN or whatever [__] I
watched that night uh that's their ESPN
up there and they go oh yeah sup you
don't say
and I realized that I had actually seen
it and was [__] out of the moment
because the people out in the Outfield
were too busy singing that soccer song
that [__]
um there's my Montreal story so anyways
uh
which always reminds me whenever I think
of the Expos is uh that [__] team
that could have been which was the 1994
Montreal Expos the one that Pedro
Martinez always gets that look in his
eye when he talks about going oh man we
will load it we were loaded they were
like the best team in baseball and then
the strike came canceled the rest of the
season and the World Series and I always
thought
that Pedro Martinez was on that team
with Randy Johnson and I believe I've
said that on the podcast and no one to
my knowledge has ever corrected me
um he wasn't
Randy Johnson
um Pedro Martinez was was Pro was part
of one of the worst trades of all
[__] time the Dodgers thought he was
too brittle too small to last and they
traded him to Montreal
for [__] Jack squat
and um
so that that trade is always brought up
but the Randy Johnson trade the exposed
trade to Seattle
whenever they do like that some you know
the top 20 worst Major League [__] uh
trades of all time it's never in there
so here's one for you here's an obscure
one because people always bring up you
know obviously the biggest one of all
time is the Red Sox you know selling
Babe Ruth
you know we traded the guy for cash so
this guy could [__]
could bankroll his wife's
Broadway play
unfucking believable unfucking
believable even unforgivable back then
because who knew what it was going to
become baseball and everything but just
[__] that that is the worst one of all
time but here's one that is and this
fascinates me worst trades of all time
that nobody bring that nobody really
brings up if you guys like to tweet me
some I'll read read some on Thursday
um or if you want to email me I'll I'll
get the thing here what is it uh the
email is
what the [__] is it
bill at the mmpodcast.com bill at the
mmpodcast.com so Expos traded Randy
Johnson
he played for them in 1988
and and looked promising
and then he started off
1989 really poorly he went he started
off Owen four
and his era was a little bit high and
they just I don't know they must have
thought he was a flash in the pan so
listen to this when the Mariners trade
Mariners traded
I should say the Expos traded Randy
Johnson to the Mariners
for Mark Langston and Mike Campbell
all right
and Seattle got Randy Johnson and then
Gene Harris Brian Holman
I believe that that was the trade and
virtually all these Seattle players were
unhappy here's something let's hear some
of the quotes third baseman Jim Presley
said so this is actually I guess
exonerates the the Expos
because if other pro baseball players
were like what the [__] did we do I
guess it's not that bad but third
baseman Jim Presley said this is a sad
day for Mariner baseball in four months
now we've lost two of the best pitchers
in Mariners history uh because they just
traded Langston and Mike Moore who
signed with Oakland and the other signed
as a free agent he's going yeah this is
a sad day I don't know what went on
whether they made him an offer or to him
or whether he wanted out of here but
maybe they should have been thinking of
how we're supposed to replace them
second baseman Harold Reynolds
Harold Reynolds who's one of my favorite
baseball people of all time he just
knows so much
this is him as a young man said this
crushes me and the reality of it all
won't hit me until we take the field
tomorrow in Milwaukee and Mike Langston
won't be there uh in defense of him that
kind of seems like he was buddies with
them but uh catcher Dave Valley just
said oh no oh no
which brings me now
to my own Boston Bruins
and we had made some very
to put it mildly aggressive [__]
moves here in the off season
um we obviously traded Milan lucich to
the chi the Kings and exchange in
exchange for the 13th overall pick
and backup goaltender Martin Jones and
defenseman Prospect Colin Miller now I
really hope in the future as I read
these names
that these some some somebody panned the
[__] out
um so here okay with the flurry of
trades and draft picks Bruins GM Don
Sweeney began a roster makeover
he really did so here's what we ended up
getting we also traded obviously we got
rid of Dougie Hamilton so here here's
what we got with our picks and I'm
hoping someday in the future
in the [__] future somebody's gonna
listen to this and say that this was a
great move because
um
you know back in the day when we traded
uh
what's his face I always forget his
[__] name
the hell's this goddamn name the guy
that we traded he wouldn't go into the
corners but he scored all the goals we
traded him to Toronto the only guy I've
seen in the NHL who he looks he has like
a pickup hockey face
he looks like he's accountant during the
week you know what I mean the only guy
I've seen with a fat face how are you
fat playing hockey
that's one thing I tell you there's no
fat [__] hockey players
not none whatsoever but somehow this guy
is [__] fat Jesus Christ hang on a
second what the [__] is this goddamn
name let me look this up here
doggy Hamilton
[__] trade there we go there we go
Bruins hurt themselves Bruins trade
Dougie Hamilton
for draft picks to the [__] Flames
Jesus Christ what the
so anyways
what is the guy's name I'm sorry
everybody right now is Phil Kessel
all right so back in the day we traded
philcastle to the Toronto Maple Leafs in
2009 for a pair of first round draft
picks that later we later use to select
Tyler Sagan and Dougie Hamilton and it
was expected according to this article
that those two players would be
cornerstones of the organization at
least for the next decade and by the way
we ended up winning the Stanley Cup with
those two guys so now we're doing it
again
we're trading again we're kind of like
the mini Blackhawks we don't win as many
we've only made we've made big [__]
moves but we've only won one so I'm
actually
willing to give Sweeney
the benefit of the doubt of course who's
getting no this is all I [__] got
what else am I gonna do
um so here's here's all the draft picks
that we got first round draft pick
number 13 the Boston Bruins select
defenseman I can't even say the guy's
name
Jacob's
zaboro 18 was third among rookie
defenseman Quebec
I don't give a [__] how big is he 13
goals 20 assists last season
then we picked this kid number 14. we
had back-to-back picks we picked a
[__] sniper
Jake dubrusk 18 six feet tall 174 pounds
Jesus Christ
I'd love to be 174 pounds I'm sorry
forward led the Western Hockey League
Swift League Swift Current in scoring
with 42 goals and 39 assists nice and
even spreading it around stick it in the
back of the [__] net number 15 we
selected this is the guy I like it's
just as far as the side Zachary
Sunny Shin I don't even say his [__]
name sanishin 18 spent last season
uh blah blah blah blah wait ah wait a
minute where's the [__] there's
somebody here is like six five
here he is
this is a guy I got hopes for number 37
defenseman Brandon Carlo 18 the 6 596
found
996 pound defenseman had four goals 21
assists sounds like he's a stay-at-home
guy
you know
I don't know I'm hoping somebody [__]
pans out that's what we got
so I'm actually kind of excited now
we're really young
[__] it Sweeney clean house what am I
gonna do
be that guy who [__] moans and complain
so hopefully some of those mean somebody
something to somebody someday right and
you guys can actually laugh that I
mispronounced all of the [__] names
you know hopefully I just mispronounced
the next [__] Wayne Gretzky
um
but anyways it's gonna be hard it's
going to be hard seeing that [__] No
Loot cheats no Dougie Hamilton Dougie
Hamilton was in the prime his [__]
career I still think that was a [__]
crazy move why do you do that
this guy's a proven guy well you know
he's probably gonna want a lot of money
well he [__] deserves it pay him
all right I'm done
let's get back to the [__] podcast
here let's get to some of the questions
here all right uh okay Romanian fan
funny you should say that Ash was
actually talking to my uh agent today
about uh
doing an Eastern European tour
I was thinking of doing two European
tours next year where I do the uh the
usual guys
Iceland over to England and then next
and then later I do [__] Scandinavia
and then down the [__] uh Baltic
states there
um hi Bill my name is Eddie I'm a 30
year old Romanian living in the UK
I'm six one and used to be 290 pounds
and in January decided to become serious
and lose weight
I got to a lowest of 217 but two months
ago I started working as a truck driver
and I'm starting to gain the weight back
I used uh I used to work in a warehouse
very physical job and also quit smoking
four months ago I listened to your
podcast I'm a big fan uh you are great
communion I only wrote to you because I
absolutely
love your way and share all your
political views dude
please put some punctuation in this I
know you mentioned my country a few
podcasts ago when you were in Paris and
your lovely wife whom I salute kindly
I love how people learn English it's so
proper I salute kindly why salute you
too kindly and I want you to know that
we Romanians are damned to be born in
the same country with those pests that
are called gypsies they ruined our name
and Country but I 100 agree with the
fact that you did a heads up for your
future holiday makers in Paris and
second of all I'm a trucker and a few
podcasts ago you were wondering if
truckers are listening to you uh well my
good man at least one surely does the
point of the email is do I continue to
do this job that I [__] love being a
trucker but probably gonna gonna
[__] all my hard work hard work of
losing weight
or do you have a piece of advice thank
you so very much yeah dude start eating
healthy
starting healthy what I would do is I
would go to the grocery store I'd have a
[__] cooler
and uh for breakfast I'd have like an
apple or an orange
I would make sure that I eat really
light and at night I would try to get on
the [__] treadmill but you have to
eat perfectly
and um you have to learn way more about
nutrition than I do
but if you love being a trucker man just
you gotta you gotta have a job you love
because then it doesn't feel like work
but if you're starting to put the weight
on
um
you know I would definitely say Don't
eat after five and I would have a giant
[__] salad with some protein every
night for dinner
get yourself a sandwich I'd crush the
[__] Waters
you know
um late night snack I do the celery with
the spoonful of peanut butter and that
gets me through now I've never tried to
be a trucker that is [__] brutal the
closest thing I've ever been to a
trucker as far as
is uh difficult to to stay in shape with
sitting in a writer's room when I sat in
the writer's room and F is for family
I put on some weight then that went into
the holidays which went into the world
tour not World Tour I wanna on the other
side of the world and then uh
you know these bus tours haven't [__]
help so
um
what I would do is I just get on the
scale see what you weigh and then next
week try to just weigh lighter that's it
even if it's just a pound because you
can't [__] work out as much I would
definitely try to be as active as you
possibly can you know what I would do I
come up this is what I do if I was you
I'd come up with the [__] truck or
work out and diet
you know write a book figure out what
works for you then turn it into a
goddamn book
and then they'll expand it not just the
truck or Diet just say hey this worked
for a guy driving a truck imagine what
it would do for you all you do is
commute they'd sell the [__] out of it
and then maybe you got enough money to
buy your own truck or start your own
Trucking Company who knows
I'll tell you right now you have a hit
book even after they're done stealing
from you you at least have time to go to
the gym all right well thank you for
listening and uh
um I don't know I'll go to Romania
someday with my pocket zipped shut
uh girlfriend's parents
hey Bill I am in eighth grade and I am
about to date this girl who is a
freshman in high school dude you [__]
crushing it unless you're a woman then
hey go easy
[Music]
yes there is a double standard your
mother would say the same thing uh the
only problem is that her parents don't
want her to date me because they think
she'll get bullied for dating a person
in a lower grade from her
oh all right okay that's interesting uh
I definitely don't want to leave the
relationship for some [__] reason so
I'm asking you and hopefully the lovely
Nia too for your guys advice on what I
should do thanks and go [__] yourself
wait the only problem is her parents
don't want her to date me
well I mean you really don't have a
choice here I mean you your only choices
I want to keep dating you it's this is
the ball is in her court it's in uh in
her court so I would just say to her say
listen I really like you
and I want to uh I want to be with you
I'd like to date you okay
um if you feel the same way I'd hope you
you'd want to keep dating me
but I can't make you date me
so uh you know that's it I'm going all
in World Series of Poker I pushed all my
chips in
you still want to be with me
I'll be down the [__] arcade tonight
at eight o'clock whatever you kids do
nowadays I'll be staring like a zombie
at my [__] PlayStation flat screen
and the surround sound
um
I don't know what do you
I don't know what what what what more
can you do other than tellity you want
to be with her
you know that's what I would do but hey
no matter what end on a good [__]
note
if she can't do it just just play this
card at your [__] age just be like
you know what I understand
you might even add this in there listen
I understand I don't want to put you in
a bad position
with your parents but I do really like
you and I would like to still be with
you and that isn't [__] right
but the parent part is setting you up
for the future because next year you're
going to be a freshman provided you
study and don't [__] up and be held back
all right don't be that guy with the
mustache in eighth grade please all
right then you get to [__] high
school
now you're in high school
you know it's not as bad sophomore
freshman who gives us nobody's going to
give a [__] you're going to the same
school you're laying the groundwork
to still be in the ball game you know
what I mean you're at bat right now the
emergency swing right now stay alive
stay alive that's what I would say stay
alive in the batter's box just say
listen
I know it's got to be tough that your
parents are giving you a rough time okay
and ultimately the decision is going to
be yours but I still want to date you
because I really like you
all right but uh I don't want to make
you miserable either so
make you know God damn it I went one
sentence too far so they make a decision
that you're comfortable with don't say
that say what the [__] I just said and
leave off that last thing all right and
then that's it
and if she [__] lets you go like I
say stay on good [__] terms
uh with her
do not
stalk her on Facebook do not pay
attention if she starts dating somebody
else
listen if she decides to walk you just
have to be like all right well maybe
next year when I'm in high school all
right
maybe then and she'll say yeah maybe
then say all right
and just say listen I'm not going to get
mad if you start dating somebody else or
something like that and then you [__]
get it out there and then you can
[__] crush it in eighth grade
you're in that dude you're already taken
down I'm in ninth grade this is like
you're going from Majors down to [__]
college ball
you know
hanging curveballs all day long sending
them into the [__] trees like The
Thrill Ride remember that one of the
first Thrill Ride [__] video
I sent you no all right all right Bill
I'm an old girlfriend my old girl I'm
old girlfriend wants baby
uh hey Billy I'm about to turn 48 and
I'm dating a great girl and she's just
turned 34. lucky me I was previously
married for 26 years and never had
children she has no baggage whatsoever
no kids no ex loser husband Etc uh she
said she would like to have at least one
kid and I think she feels time is
running out I kind of think I am I'm too
old but I don't want to lose her I like
kids but they seem like a lot of work
[Laughter]
I don't know those kids you know they
seem like a lot of work
said it seemed like a lot of work even
if completely healthy Jesus Christ dude
even more if they have any issues
Jesus dude I can you know you're one of
those guys that shouldn't have had kids
not sure I got the energy for that I
want to travel and go to shows and drink
and continue to be selfish but in some
way it sounds kind of cool please help
maybe Nia has a take
P.S Stuart Copeland is the greatest
drummer of all time capital and you know
it's true uh yeah he's one of the greats
and if that's your greatest drum of all
time I wouldn't argue that you know to
each his own
um
hey dude if you want to do it go ahead
and do it I don't think you're too old
you know
and I think it's really like as far as
like
the work it's it's the first I think
three four years once they get around
five and they kind of know right from
wrong then you kind of got a buddy he's
still gonna be a pain in the ass but you
know he's going to the bathroom himself
you know or herself or whatever they
kind of know right from wrong
and then they think you're a God so like
the next [__] seven years even though
they're still gonna throw temper
tantrums and [__] by the time they're
seven or eight I mean you
if you did the [__] job and you
raised them right you got to have a
pretty cool kid
and then uh you know enjoy the next five
years because then once they become
teenagers they think they [__] know
everything and just pray to God they
don't get Knocked Up or knock somebody
up or get addicted to drugs
it's really once they turn 13 you're
just trying to get them through
education getting a good job and not
marrying a [__] psycho
and if you do that then I think then you
can finally [__] breathe a little bit
that's what it seems like but um
yeah it's a lot of work but there's a
part of you that I think wants to do it
so if you want to do it I would say do
it now
it's now or never all right ex lady
called me up
hey Billy [__] tits hey easy Jesus
Christ I hope you're meeting your weight
loss goals I love listening to your
podcast at the gym yada yada yada yada
go [__] yourself
uh oh speaking of Drummond by the way I
did the goddamn Comedy Jam three times
last week I got to play out live in a
club man what a [__] what a thrill
that is
what a [__] throw you know I want to
thank Josh Adam Meyers and everybody uh
in the band Joel J and Nick for putting
up with me in my awful [__] playing
um I was actually totally relaxed the
whole week when I was playing you know I
[__] up a lot but uh I just kept going
I didn't drop time too much you know I
don't think I you know I [__] up
Phil's there's a couple you know double
hits in the bass drum that I like
sounded like mud but whatever snare was
right there on the two and four nobody
noticed
um but what a [__] great time that is
I can't imagine traveling with three
other people and being in a band and
being [__] broke but I I can tell you
right now
sitting behind a set of drums you know
best seat in the [__] house watching
everybody else in the band going [__]
nuts
and actually seeing people like into it
is is one of the [__] coolest things
I've ever got to do
so I'll be doing a lot more of those in
the future why the [__] not they're fun
as hell
anyways I love listening to your podcast
at the gym yada yada yada go [__]
yourself I need some advice about this
ex lady
I used to date a few years back at the
end of college she recently sent me a
message wanting to hang out I asked her
about her situation situation from a
friend the lady is moving in in seven
weeks
and uh and quit a job
wait a minute I just started daydreaming
halfway through that I was thinking
about drumming isn't that weird you can
actually do that well somebody else
keeps reading and talking
all right I need some advice about this
actually I used to stay a few years back
she recently sent me a message wanting
to hang out asked what a situation the
lady is
moving in seven seven weeks and quit a
job I figured she was looking for a
quick fling before she left ah
bill I thought I had struck gold I
really did one and a half months of No
Strings Attached fun and then she would
just be [__] gone you idiot you
probably saw her too much and now she
thinks there's a reason to stay
never have to see her again anyways I
agree to hang out with her and that's
when she tells me that she is homeless
ah Jesus Christ
she's homeless how the [__] is she
calling you
she [__] up her lease and is out seven
weeks before she leaves so now I'm
hanging out with her
in one week my question for you
parentheses and maybe a wife
could help uh add some female charm to
the answer how do I bang her oh my God
but not have to let her live with me for
two months you know what I gotta put
down the mic for half a second and just
applaud you for admitting to the exact
selfish piece of [__] thing that you
want to do hang on a second
to love honesty you know like the what
somebody wants to do I think she I
should probably just go for it and worry
about that situation later what do you
think thank you and please go [__]
yourself a redheaded dope like yourself
all right my freckles and arms here
um
all right how do I bang her but not have
to live with her
oh simple you just put her up in a motel
and you say you're going to pay for it
that's what I would do that's [__]
filthy man Jesus Christ put her up in a
[__] hotel would be cheap she's not
[__] homeless she'll feel obligated
to bang you you're already banging
before it won't feel so filthy that's
what you could do
I might need a shower after this [__]
answer but that I would just say that
that's the way to go uh by no means let
her ever stay over at your house do not
ever [__] her over at your house [__]
her at the motel that you put her up in
that's what you need to do okay she
cannot come over your [__] house if
she asks you why just say just be honest
just be honest just say because I'm not
you know what dude
um
this is really [__] up she's calling
you in a time of need she's calling you
because she's homeless
lady's moving in seven weeks and quit
her job oh dude she might be on drugs
she [__] up or at least she's moving I
don't know dude
I don't know man you might be [__] a
somebody who's uh using needles here man
you know what I say dude I got one for
you why don't you [__] rub one out
and then think about it
oh he says P.S when is your next special
coming out I think I speak for everyone
when I say I can't wait to see him
that's very nice of you um well I put
them out every two years so I came out
the last one came out in December every
little more than two years so this is my
year off where I just get to [__] around
and have a great time which I'm doing
and um
I've already you know I have some ideas
about where I want to shoot my next one
what I want it to look like and I'm just
waiting for the material to come but uh
I'm really I'm really happy I'll tell
you I'm really I'll tell you I'm really
happy with where my Act was this past
weekend when I was up in Montreal uh all
right let me read the rest of this
the rest of the uh
advertising here and then I got a
dilemma and a couple of overrated
underrated remember those all right all
right dilemma
would you rather do a show with no
swearing or take a bath with Oprah also
with no swearing
um I wouldn't subject Oprah to taking a
bath with me I do a show not swearing
I've done that I can do that
um
underrated overrated these are from me
underrated calling in a night
that's what I learned when I was in
Montreal when I wasn't drinking and I
was just sitting there slamming Waters
and everything it got to that [__]
point like you know what there's a point
where you saw everything that's going to
happen everything else is just going to
get messy get home now we can still wake
up early and [__] work out uh also
underrated drinking Waters while
everyone else is getting [__] up it's
tremendous it's tremendous
everybody starts slurring they say crazy
[__] to you and right as they get just
completely not even tolerable you just
[__] walk out and they don't even
notice
um also underrated working out in the
morning
stepping on the scale after pushing a
buck 90 a month ago and seeing 180 180.0
all right overrated After parties rich
food and buying new [__]
you buy new [__] and then it gets with
your old [__] next thing you know your
[__] room is full
filled up you know what I mean you got
to get underrated getting rid of [__] I
got stuff in my garage I have old DVDs
would you guys still buy DVDs if I put
them up on my website I'll autograph all
of them just to get them out of my
garage I'm gonna do it I think there's a
few older people out there listening to
the podcast that are old school like me
and they want you know they want the
gold behind their money they don't want
to digitally own it they want to have
the hard copy
um all right that's gonna be the podcast
for this week uh what a week I had man
Montreal Ottawa you guys were
unbelievable such great fans up there uh
the goddamn Comedy Jam
Josh Joel J and Nick thank you guys for
putting up with my drumming and uh thank
you to everybody that came out to my
shows
um
what else what else
who else did I want to thank God damn it
I can't [__] remember
anyways
I'm the worst I gotta stay you know I
did all right this week I actually made
some lists anyways this is going to take
me forever to upload because my internet
sucks so I got an hour and 10 minutes
here you guys have a good weekend on
Thursday I'll check in on you there all
right go [__] yourselves I'll talk to
you later